In Israel, the government revokes 83,000 permits for Palestinians in the West Bank,...
...barring them from entering the country after a gunman attack in Tel Aviv.
Police in Italy say five alleged human smugglers...
...have been detained in the Sicilian port of Pozzallo...
...after being apprehended at sea with 223 migrants.
In Iraq, the Islamic State releases a video...
...of the destruction of a 3,000-year-old Assyrian temple...
...at the city of Nimrud in the north of the country.
Workers in France continue to strike across the nation...
...one day before the Euro 2016 soccer tournament is set to kick off.
And finally from Thailand, people line the streets...
...celebrating King Bhumibol Adulyadej's 70th year on the throne...
...amid concerns of his health before constitutional referendum.